hello everyone and welcome to the second
match of dual endorse a be rapid
challenge finals it's Hikaru Nakamura
versus then you'll do both and this is
Game one now in match 1 and Nakamura was
victorious he want two and a half one
and a half and now if you do go wants to
get back in the match he needs to win
this match and then go into the third
match
so now we'll see what happens already
Game one is very exciting Nakamura with
the white pieces goes for efore sorry
about that
we have c5 by do both going for the
Sicilian 1953 9th to c6 and now Nakamura
doesn't go for the for the open with the
d4 but rather see 3d all up in variation
of the Sicilian and okay Knight of 6 we
have E 5 9th to d5 and Bishop to c4 so
this is all very standard Knights to b6
puts pressure on the bishop the bishop
e3 and now c4 brush it back to C to end
now of course d5 grabbing scent and
grabbing the center now which Nakamura
decides to capture out of us all
so eek a person b6 Queen captures and
now just castles so Bishop to g4
developing and pinning that night and
Queen to e2 we have Queen side castles
by do both and now Knight to a3 going
after that c4 pawn and here there are
some games where Queen to f6 was played
also there he 5 is a non moving the
position but Quinta ESS by dubov is a
new move so already as a move 11 we have
a completely new game at dubov offers
the Queen trade now which Nakamura goes
for we have Queen captures and e6 Bishop
captures and now b3 you want to get the
rid of this c4 pawn so you can finally
get this d4 pony and because if just
before then you will again lose the pawn
here any kind of don't want to have it
there all the way to d2 as it's a
backwards pawn you cannot develop your
bishop we get your books into the game
and so on so b3 preparing to capture on
c4 and Bishop to d5 now we have D
captors on c4 Knight captures on c4
Knight captures and Bishop captures and
now a Nakamura doesn't go for d4 right
away first he goes to rook to e1 of
course if you go d4 you're gonna lose
the
here so rook to e1 and here Bishop to d3
now dubov doesn't allow d4 he wants
Nakamura to keep his backwards D to pawn
so here Nakamura trait we have
characters captors and looked at e3
now either forcing the rule back or or
hoping for a trade here so look back the
d7 y du Bois and now again not going for
d4 Nakamura goes for Bishop to e3 with
the idea that after East 645 you can
just gobble up the bishop on f8 which Du
Bois goes for with E 5 now yes there's a
double attack here but also if the
knight moves and also route characters
and e2 will be an idea so best of
character Sunday faith we have route
characters on f8 and now again not doing
anything with the D pawn but first h4
making some room for the king also
preparing h5 but now instead of h4 you
could have perhaps to go a gun for
Knight captures an e5 but then again you
give up the d2 phone you will be left
with the isolated C and a pawn so a
Nakamura decides that he prefers to keep
his D to bond so f6 by du Bois
strengthening the e5 pawn and now h5 and
now rook F to d8
again I putting pressure on the D to
pawn with King to f1 and now b6 making
room for the King to enter the game g3
and now King the b7 we have King to g2
and now Knight to e7 the knight is no
longer needed here as the 5 phone is
nicely protected and you wanna re
maneuver it somewhere else maybe you can
get it the d5 to attack the rook and
from there you can also go to all sorts
of squares or maybe you can go something
like f5 d 6b 5 and so on so rook to e4
and now with more control of the d4
square so maybe you can get some rook to
d1 to d4 moves in however route to d3
now now dubov doesn't allow it and
although it was never a mistake for
Nakamura not to play d4 by allowing the
pond to remain on b2 it's just a it's
just a big problem for the rest of the
game but ok with a 4 by Nakamura and now
Knight to c6 not the knife can now come
to a5 to be 3 or maybe a 5 in dentist
for and you can put additional pressure
to the d2 pond with the night as well as
the rooks are already nicely doubled on
the D file so rook the ytube Nakamura
has to set up a defense here and Knights
to a5 the night will now join in the
attack on the d2 pawn so rook to a two
defending amount night the c-4 adding a
third attacker and now just g4 dd-do
bone is nicely defended we rotate the d5
adjust grabbing more space increasing
the activity of the rooks and here
Nakamura has to decide whether he just
wants to repeat moves as he doesn't
really have any active plans for example
King g3 was taking c6 you were gonna go
back in g2 h 16 g3 and so on and it's
hard to say how black will improve black
is of course better he has a much more
active King much more active pieces but
it's unclear where he will create his
breakthrough so here instead of going
for four passivity Nakamura goes at
night Stage four he wants to go night at
five put some pressure on the pawns here
and maybe create a passed pawn of his
own on the Kings side but it comes with
a price of one point so double grabs it
rook captures and e2 and now Knight to
f5 attacking the g7 pawn we rock out for
Sonny to rook captures and now g6 we
have aged characters H characters and
now Knight to e7 with an attack and an
rook end and the pawn here and now rook
the d7 by du Bois problem is if you
capture here then rook the g7 the knight
has to move and the duel again will win
upon so Nakamura goes Knight the g8 here
puts pressure on the f6 bone but now f5
and dubov gets to keep his extra pawn so
CalPERS captures and now Knight to H
explaining more pressure on the pawn
here
rook the g7 check by dubov king of three
and now comes to rook to g5 just
defending this and the pawns are making
it
that's a weird arrow whoa the pawns are
making it impossible for the King to
reach either of them so Knights the f7
again pressuring the rook rook aged five
and now kink the g3 we have looked at h7
and going after the night Knight to g5
and now rook the d7 preparing rock to
the
three check to gobble up the c3 pawn as
well so now there isn't really all that
much for Nakamura to do here he's down
upon and he's positional isn't all that
great he goes king to h4 he wants to go
King h5 to g6 and maybe gobble up the
pawns this way
so dubab immediately goes after the pawn
we have king h5 rook captures on c3
and here comes the moment from the title
of the video here Nakamura has to go of
course king g6 trying to put pressure on
these pawns but he goes came to h6 now
this was a mouse slip there is no other
way around it and it's it's really
interesting this concept of mouse slips
in elite chess so when it's online
of course Nakamura would never play such
a move as the move makes no sense you
have to play King g6 and go after the f5
pawn but it's there's no way to do not
allow such things for example that there
should be maybe there's some some
Overlord overseeing the game that would
say okay that's impossible for Nakamura
to play a move like that we should allow
him to take back the move however it's
not really possible
you know until until they start playing
with let's say some sort of a neural
interface mouse slips are bound to
happen so here are Nakamura played King
to h6 which of course he was in a worse
position and now he gives a doob of a
tempo and it's just not helping him and
here if you don't think that it was a
mouse leap here is Nakamura's reaction
after this move so there you have it
there you can see the that's what
happened when he played king h6 he
doesn't believe he committed this mouse
slip but it does happen
so King h6 and now to book is just one
move closer to victory king c6 now King
g6 by nakamura and f4 now
sorry ffff for by black not allowing the
capture we have Knight to e4 and now
comes Luke to a3 offering a trade and of
course going after the a for pawn so
Roxy - attacking the knight and now just
rook characters on a4 so now dubov is up
three points which is of course
completely winning but nakamura will do
his best not to not to lose this here b5
Google now start pushing his passport
and rook the c1 rook to a3 and now rook
to d1 there's not much you can do but
wait for do both to push his pawn before
rook the d8 maybe you can deliver some
checks from behind but Knights the b6
not allowing it King capture Sonny 5 but
now b3 Deauville doesn't care about
pawns here rip the d6 checking the b5
and rook to d1 and now King Tubby for
now getting the King closer in not
allowing it in any Forks any Knight to
c3 check ideas and here Nakamura could
grab yet I'm not a pawn but it doesn't
help him just be two rook to be one and
now Knight see for King b3 defends the
pawn rook to e1 and the next move will
win there's not much you can do here so
King the d4 by Nakamura but now rook to
a5 now you will go behind the King maybe
grab the rook so Knight to c3 but it was
also in this position after Knight to c3
that hikaru nakamura resigned the game
and game 1 of the second match goes to
do both as there is nothing more to be
done here the idea is the same you're
gonna push b2 and after the blue blocks
of course you're gonna play either King
b3 or Knight to c4 and next move rook to
e1 wins the game and if 91 let's say you
want to win the pawn then just king b3
you had another defender not the Knight
and King are defending the pawn and the
rook to a 1 wins the game on the next
move yeah after this Knight to c3
nakamura resigns and do both wins the
game we can check out this this blunder
blunder reaction one more time just just
for the fun of it so let's let you enjoy
this there there you go it just you know
it they're playing online mouse lips
will happen and we just have to get used
to it so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Kieran signing our Brandon Quentin Geoff
graves
Robert forward and David Brown for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual we
can check to my previous video Sarah
thing go for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the
window rossabi rapid challenge finals
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day